就這麼簡單跟你說
但它的甚麼全是文件
全是一些文字 沒了
它就是讓AI更懂你的一個東西
那你下次再重復用它的時候
不用再教它一遍了
直接出來搞定
好 甚麼問題啊
我問一下
就是你這個界面是甚麼界面
我現在搞不懂這個界面是Codex的還是GetHub的
GitHub啊
這是我上傳上去我的課程員工
我們其實連GetHub都沒用過
我都不知道在哪打開
你說你不可能在一小時學會
你不用那麼焦慮
你問AI一套是甚麼不就完了嗎
我知道就是
我得把這個年紀 我都度你的相回去問
慢慢搞 慢慢搞
不用著急不用焦慮
我只是給你們一個啓發
懂嗎
就是照給AI員工長甚麼樣的
你要甚麼步驟把它構建出來
你知道那個夠了
細節你不用知道太多
你做的時候遇到問題問AI就好了
OK嗎
聽的也不用太焦慮
聽不懂正常
因為你都沒用過
我這個東西
對吧
也不是一兩天做出來的
OK
然後你看到了它的效果
就是我一句話
一個視頻它出來了
一個我想要的東西結束
那中間一堆的Harness
都是AI寫的
而且每一步都是我出錯了
告訴AI哪裡出錯
給它證據
幫我寫成Harness
控制好它
下一次不要再犯錯了
OK了
好
好接下來我又做了一個升級啊
我後面覺得啊
這個做視頻啊對吧
反正它的任務呢
它並不是有衝突的
我做第一張跟第二個PPT
它是可以並行的
對吧
所以我我後來就做了一個升級
直接並行生產
因為我嫌得太慢了
每次發開一個視頻
對吧
它生產很久才生產出來
那甚麼叫並行呢
就我把一個視頻發給它
你幫我拆成五張一起生產
它就同步一起生產
最後合在一起
效率會快了五倍
只是會燒你的電腦的一些
CPU跟內存等等的事情
所以HUNNUS呢
就是慢慢進化了
你發現問題
哇太慢了
哇這裡不對
這裡不對
升級
然後鎖定HUNNUSB2
升級了已經
對吧
然後下一步你又覺得哪裡還可以升級
直接密伸
不斷的去迭代
這就是你的員工你的系統
好
所以我說了這節課最關鍵的
其實就是HUNNUSB2的一個環節
因為很多人可能自己用的話
完全沒有想過可以這麼做
他就是應來跟他瘋狂的對話
瘋狂的操作
但是呢
我說暫停
他先想清楚了
然後給他錯誤的東西
因為你硬做你的執行能力
跟你的那個比不過AI的
所以不要跟他硬做
OK
好接下來我給他介紹一個
比較前前的工具
我說我在學習AR的過程
其實最高效的就是
去到最前前的工具裡面
看他到底做了啥
為甚麼可以這麼強大
這麼多star
這麼多星星
直接看他的圓滿
那到底這個效果做了甚麼
他跟傳統的軟件有甚麼區別
哇這個真的很厲害
傳統的軟件呢
屬於我寫死一個功能
對吧
一堆代碼
你有這個功能
一個按鍵
按鍵就有個功能在了
對吧
但新型的軟件呢
是我把AI智能體
嵌到這個軟件裡面了
他包括有LUNCHIN
和LANDGRAPH
就是我可以有智能體
他自動的在這個軟件裡面
就能調用大模型
並且我可以有很多個智能體
在這個軟件裡面
才是新型的開發
所以我們來看一下
一個投資的一個agent
確定agent
在技術上面
大數量非常多的
那到底怎麼做的呢
好
再來給大家一個很好的一個提示
就是你在做一個系統
還做一個項目之前
第一步你就要乾嘛
除了創建Hug
如果你都沒想法
你要怎麼做第一步
甚麼
想起的要求還不是
還真不是
是甚麼
其實呢
這個也是另外一個skill
在agent
在那個codex裡面
排名前幾了
他是做甚麼呢
幫你搜索市面上最好的文章
最好的工具
最好的skill
最好的開源工具
沒能做過甚麼樣子的
他直接能搜出來
copy到你的本地
讓你學習
對吧
比如說
啊我需求
沒錯我想到了
我想炒美股賺錢啊
對吧
難道我跟AI說
我想賺錢這樣子
不可能
所以我第一步
我要去
聽號上面搜
有沒有是符合我用的工具
這第一個
或者有沒有一些符合我的文章
直接上去
它自動的
它有一個硬核條件
是甚麼
你要讓AI幫你裝這個python
3.10以上的
那你以前很難啊
要找個技術來幫你裝
現在
直接跟AI說我要裝這個
你甚至說我要裝這個
Agent Reach
就夠了
他說你缺這個缺那個
授權
搞定
所以不要想太複雜
第一個Agent Reach
就是Codex裡面最厲害的
搜索工具
包括你要搜同類型的文章
你看我那個Lotion
這麼多AI的文章
對吧
全是用Agent Reach
!收出來的
我只是給他一個方向而已
我需要學AI的這些文章
一百篇就出來了
然後用CMI直接塞到你的自治庫
結束
所以說我們是不是
哇
收完了以後下載一個T-HOP的項目
我就有數字員工了
不是啊
首先你要先知道誰來用它
對吧
它的數據來源是甚麼
怎麼失敗的
這個是人要去做的
它肯定不可能
一下載下來就能掛人了
對吧
你要你最後輸出是長甚麼樣的
你要用成甚麼樣子的東西
要人工批准啊
人運行
人解釋
人追責
OK
那我們來看一下
TradingAgents
厲害的地方了
就我有個疑問
哇
這只是假設
我就說
我好想買英偉達的股票
但我不知道現在這個股價怎麼樣
業績怎麼樣
那以前我們要怎麼樣
打開一堆的甚麼富途牛牛啊
上Google啊
送這個公司財報
剛公佈的財報
對吧
8月26號公佈的英偉達財報
業績非常牛逼
那代表甚麼呀
對吧
那現在是市值
值不值這個錢啊
我啥也不知道
一收亂七八糟的信息
我還要主張去想
那完蛋了呀
對吧
最後我的決策練路這麼長
並且決策的過程
數據又不完整
練路又長
那最後的決策
科不科學
我也不知道
都是主觀的
對吧
那這個Agent 他做了甚麼事情呢
好我們做的步驟啊
第一個我們先用Agent Beach
去收到底能滿足你需求的
有甚麼工具
在T-Hot上面
人家已經開發的很完善了呀
然後呢
你用Agent去讀它的結構
到底它乾了甚麼事情
對吧
有甚麼核心的流程
然後第三步呢
你不要想這樣很複雜
都是那Agent做的
就是那你的Coldest做
第三步就把它刻錄到本地
下載下來
試用一下
能不能省查
能不能回滾啊
能不能試用一下
最後用Coldest
對吧
你想二次開發
隨便你開發
你也可以下載別的Agent
滿足你工作的
你想要二次開發
你就先用Agent解釋完
再講清楚你的需求
調給Superpower
對吧
直接幫你開改
改完了
好
那我們來這裡呢
很好玩的呀
我已經
對
雖然我講基礎呢
不是講的很好
但是我都是有準備的
我在網站上面呢
你可以直接打開這個
這個啊
是我當時調用它的時候給的POM
簡單到你不相信
你之前聊過天的GPT
你都可以保存的呀
就是你的聊天記錄可以保存的呀
OK
我已經放在網站上了
這裡啊
打開就是了
這簡單到你都不相信
我就
其實我用HP早就知道這個項目了
我就說
啊
我想用這個滿足我的需求
我想調研這個AI板塊的股票
我可以怎麼借用啊
這個工具的數據層
對吧
它的前端展示
!是怎麼實現的
要不要錢啊
對吧
先問它
它直接回答你啊
AI股有這些
對吧
英偉達
AMD等等
建議的工作流
等等等等啊
這些我是看的懂
因為我本身做這行的
所以它是直接
它瞭解我
因為我之前一直用Python代碼
所以它直接返回給我Python代碼
就裡面
是甚麼結構的
數據
數據怎麼實現的
對吧
你先瞭解它
那關鍵就這兩個工具了
新型軟件才有的
經常聽到的
LongChain跟這個LongGraph
就是說
我有一個長面路
跟AI大模型去調度的
再來管理一個多元功能
都在裡面了
他寫在裡面了
我就通過這個來學習了
我後面想開發一個科研的項目
就通過這個項目去學習
我都不用寫代碼
我都讓AI去做
對吧
他數據路由哪來的
是雅虎的
finance
還有一些
Fed
就是美聯儲的
Point Market等等的數據來源
還有情緒的
包括一些推達
還有不配的等等
他有一些地方
可以拿到一些情緒的數據
原來數據是這樣子的
然後Dashboard怎麼實現
他說他沒有Dashboard
只能用命令行
那也OK
你後面有需要
你自己讓他寫個Dashboard就可以了
你有需要讓他寫
就變成你的工作台了
對吧
然後他有沒有甚麼權限啊
甚麼都沒有
他就是一個
一個幫你多個員工去辯論的一個工具
你看我命令行
我的POM現在就用了一句話而已
要不要費用啊
是要的
因為他裡面就會自動調用大模型
數據是不用錢的
很多數據不用錢
但是呢
你要調那個大模型是要錢的
例如
默認是5.5的
然後呢
我後來發現我的GMP是會員制的
沒有API
所以我就直接用了DipSea
DipSea直接把你的API輸進去
那就可以
幫你完成這個分析啊
然後我自己有需求哦
我說
哎你就分析一個英偽答不行啊
我要分析20支
對吧
我要對比一下這20支哪支更好
然後呢
我自己還想加一些分析進去
來做這個事情
然後你看他先幫我講清楚了
這個項目是長這樣的
你有了股票代碼
有了分析日期
他有分析師
分析價格的
分析新聞的
分析情緒的
分析公司財報的
最後呢
這裡這個Soutoken
這裡呢是
拿到數據直接腳本
開始分析
然後分析完呢
這兩邊呢
就開始調大模型
再辯論了
多空辯論
最後
研究經理來決策
告訴你
哪些是可以買的
哪些是不能買的
OK
那怎麼安裝
他也告訴你了
那API怎麼輸
你輸你的
你想要用的大模型
就可以了
第一次測試呢
他都給你建議了
所以其實是
不要想的太複雜
就是我們要知道
我們要用哪個工具
先讓那個
Agent Reach
去收到這個工具
然後讓他
讓你先瞭解這個工具
然後你才能二次改造它
變成服務你的一個
變成服務你的一個機器人
好這些數據都支持了
然後我就可以直接測試一下
對吧
這些你們可以回去再看
我已經存在我的那個教學的網線上面
然後基本上他的代碼
幫我已經幫我改寫完了
我也沒寫一行代碼
幫我改寫完
20支股票的真心
對吧
寫完了
最好不要一次性調用
就是那個專行的去調用
一個一個來運行
不要一次性調
可能你就會超出請求啊
請求限制啊等等
好這裡呢
這裡呢這裡複雜了一點點啊
就是你它需要你寫你的一個
模型的API
這就是新型軟件啊
它裡面就欠了
智能體和調用大模型的模式
它是這個功能就是這個功能
而是你每次給他不同的數據
他都能給你實時的一個新的東西出來
是思考過推理過的
而不是死的一個東西
ok
好我是我就問了
哎呀我又不是
我又我只是
我只是破的會員
我沒有API
然後後面就就就就
就調用成了Dipshift
DeepSeek
也可以
好
然後最後就試一下
對吧
就出來了
這報告就出來了
包括英偉拿最新採報的分析等等等等
ok
那我們看一下它出來的結果啊
這壓根我就想了三句話
沒了
英偉拿看一下
27號的報告對吧
直接做成了這麼詳細的
對吧
AI股票報告
!它的財報增長多少啊對吧
Q2直接漲飛了
賺了960公元億
毛利率
毛利率直接75%
各種報告啊
甚麼業務分析等等等等啊
價格分析
情緒分析
還有宏觀
!甚麼加息不加息
都有
因為它已經把所有的數據給了
調用了那幾個Agent
跟大模型聊過了
才出了這個報告
最後多空辯論
給你一個結論
拉到最後就可以了
這個這個效果
其實它是大很多的
它的建議是趕緊買
對吧
那你當然可以人工審查一下
哈哈
我只是給大家演示了一遍
甚麼叫
人家現在開發的工具已經是這麼先進了
有多Agent在裡面
有實時調用API
去調大模型的一個功能
所以我現在研發的科研的自己工作的項目
我都會調用這樣的一些思路了
對吧
怎麼讓它實時跟大模型對話
燒這個API token
最後怎麼調用多個智能體
怎麼部署成服務
等等等等啊
怎麼控製成本
OK
好
是沒改動過的版本啊
就是我都沒有讓它
做20支股票的對比
然後最後呢做成了20支
OK
都是英文的
中文
20支
然後就對比啊
這個是芯片板塊的
這個是雲計算的
數據中心的
對吧
然後AI軟件的
OK
已經是二次開發了
你寫了你的Hardless
跟你的一個想法進去
它直接就把你開發了
然後你想把它做成服務很簡單
你把這個Agent直接找一台本地電腦也行
雲服務器也行
你就說
每周幫我自動跑一次
發到我郵箱
或者每天
對吧
它就可以每天幫給你啊
你都不用自己瞎分析了
打開
哦
因為這麼厲害
別的股票怎麼樣
等等等等
那你要改它
你覺得這個數據我覺得不行
不滿意
我要換一個數據
你再跟A說那可以吧
OK
所以你可以看到它的一個結構啊
就是
我用了哪些數據
然後怎麼辯論
怎麼損准
怎麼掉大模型的
最後怎麼做決策的
你這個每一個環節啊
你都可以去更改了
然後最後變成分析20支某個板塊
都可以
這個水裡面
但是你要先理解它
你才能更改它啊
好
這就是我做的流程了
大家可以看一下
那最關鍵就是兩個新的技術
以前沒有自能體的時候
是沒有這兩個玩意的
浪漫就是說我在這個軟件裡面
這個項目裡面
它可以知道怎麼去發體試詞啊
跟大模型交互啊
拿到上下文啊
最後持續的
有一個一串的
一串的一個路的一個
智能體去做事
那怪不得
我是怎麼去分工的啊
怎麼交互的呀
怎麼去完成
A到B
再到A
無限循環
那這個呢
就是我們
哎
這個呢
就是我們
哎
這個呢
新的項目
部署成服務
怎麼跟AI去
真正的去
能夠實現交互的一個做法
所以你看
我學習的方式
!直接進去
搜關鍵詞
看它代碼
對吧
乾了甚麼事情
哦
這個基本面分析師
要用甚麼
提示詞
全部寫在裡面啊
那這個line graph
就是說我要調用甚麼
工具節點
這個
這些調用了甚麼工具
你看這個
基本面分析師
調用了幾個
宏觀數據
等等等等啊
每個都是
你看新聞
基本面
社
社交媒體的
跟價格數據
它都是有些節點在的
所以這個給我很大的啓發
就是我現在在做一些
新的科研的項目
我就得想
怎麼把這些一些
跟大網星實時交互的
邏輯加進去
它能夠幫我發現更多新的東西
這就是
哎
大網星本身自己做不到
你要去
給它額外添加的一個功能
好
所以我說Multi-Agent
甚麼時候才值得啊
到底你這些
證據能不能拆啊
各有各的輸入
對吧
你有很多指揮
你才真的要用到那個Multi-Agent
這個項目就很
給你一個很好的案例啊
每個Agent
其實負責的數據是不一樣的
所以它是可以拆開來工作的
然後交付出來的
又要結合在一起
一起分析
對吧
然後結論怎麼生成出來的
它需要花多少時間
它都有追溯的
那個
因為把那個報告寫的很詳細的
每個人是甚麼觀點的
最後辯論是甚麼樣子的
來源是甚麼樣的
最後買不買肯定是你自己負責了
對啊
因為賺了虧了
跟這個Agent沒有關係啊
所以我自己呢
就是除了在它上面學習以外
我也可以在它上面做個次開發
就是讓它下次我給它一個命令
它自己就知道
選哪個十隻股票
做甚麼
做甚麼分析
最後給一個甚麼報告啊
以前的開發啊
跟大家可能想象的非常難
現在我就講了一句話
沒了
幫我開發二十隻
這二十隻
對吧
然後要甚麼報告
講清楚
我調的Supra Power
就做
就完了
數據你看
你可以下到本地
你也可以創一個數據庫
如果你平次高的話
你可以創數據庫來保存
最後的報告就告訴你
哪些是要
這個是
財報還沒出來的時候的
那十字的對比啊
這個是拿著
這個是要
增加持有
這個是要減倉等等
它給了你足夠的數據跟原因
你可以打開看這個報告
這個報告
出海的一個產品
那我這邊再推薦給大家一個skill啊
這個是中文的也有英文的
兩個
它把市面上一百多個職業全部蒸餾了
有了有做前端的有做小紅書有做平台銀銀有做增長的
你就直接上去複製下來就可以了
然後讓它幹活 OK
我這邊給它稍微打開一下
這個還是比較厲害的
我剛有的時候不會用KITHO什麼直接都不會用
它就是個網站打開
Agency Agent
這個是英文版的下面這個是中文版的
你看一下這個
你都不用想著
剛剛有人問怎麼克隆它下來的
不需要你把這個連接發給Codex
對吧
我需要用它裡面的哪一個
你就把它克隆下來就完了
現在不用自己不用打開命令行的
各行各業啊
100多個職業嚇死了
全部被蒸餾了
你真的有什麼
你直接把這個企業的所有的很專業的一些
步驟
工作步驟
有時候我才做過網站
打開
它就是
就是前端開發的SKILL啊
它做什麼的
對嗎
我就把它拒絕一下接以後它就完了
它就知道了
這就是其中一個HUNNESS
你把這就是Agent.MD
就告訴這個文件
告訴大模型
這個文件就是幹這個網頁的
所以我其實你看到我做了報名網站啊
知識網站啊
這些網站你們都有用過了嘛
報名啊還有學習啊對吧
!都是分開的文件夾裡面
就是這些Agent在裡面幹活
我每次都一句話馬上更新改版
發布等等
那就是把這個
沒有報料的它自己給你安裝
但是你得在電腦上專門給它設置
一些文件夾
啊對對對就是工作區嘛
我這邊再簡單弄一下
你看這電腦我平時沒用的
因為筆記本我就是拿來玩的
沒有工作的文件在裡面啊
你就在這裡創建一個新對話
這個
我們去做設計
或者是印件的版本
所有的內容都要成功
不需要
誒?你說我把手禮這裡
創建一個項目對吧
!然後呢
你就在這裡
其實跟管理文件是一樣的
你就在這裡創建一個員工
你說是
是
做網站的對吧
website
ok
進去了是吧
確認
好進來了
ok
然後第一步幹什麼啊
搞hanness啊
對吧
第一步直接說
不是不是
直接給他這個
因為你這個
你看看那個
因為你想做前端
所以你要講到前端相關的描述
對吧
然後呢
這裡有前端嗎
對吧
開開
直接複製給他就可以了
對吧
這個
這個是GPT Conex啊
對啊
就你直接說人話就行了
我需要
我自己就GPT
我就不需要再裝了可財
不用可財
現在可財了
這裡面就有
哦
我就
我都
我
反正你就是把這個佈置給他
幫我穿一個這個
這個
穿一個這個
也是
對
他他拿出來
在你的文件裡面創一個
下次再用的時候
他就知道這個文件是幹啥的了
哦
待會吧
我們先過一遍啊
因為這裡你看工程部啊
前端後台 AI工程師什麼都有開發師
下面設計部
OK
UI設計師
這些我們不知道是啥
UX
好
提思池工程師
我這個還有個新星
就你想做啥你就來
複補貼
都可以
然後你就把這個複製到一個很低就可以了
對吧
小黃樹團隊有哪些人在啊
哦
運營的
品牌手部的內容創造
等等啊
但我大部分工作是科研工作
所以我其實暫時沒有太玩這種
媒體的東西
所以我後面也會也會
試起來
因為很多東西就是AI做的對吧
你只要多一台電腦
多一台CPU
多一台服務器
不就是多一個員工嗎
我在嘗試了
但是肯定做的沒有
做了很多年的的好啊
對啊對
OK
其實我們也就是
把我們平常啊
就無私的給大家
傳授這些知識啊
OK
看看大家還有甚麼問題這一塊
因為呢我們本身文件裡面的總文件